there's really very little controversy
that this industry has been growing very
rapidly over the last couple of decades
if you take the year 2010 by itself
there were about 17 gigawatt of new
power installed in that particular year
and what's remarkable about that number
is that it really represents the
cumulative total of all installations
ever since the inception of that
industry in the 1970s
over the last two years 2011 and 12
we've also maintained
pretty impressive growth rates of about
20
annually
now what should also be kept in mind
when we think about this solar
photovoltaic industry at this point
is that it enjoys
considerable public subsidies in
particular through the tax code and the
so-called federal investment tax credit
and the other thing that has been
happening is that
panel prices solar panel prices have
come down very rapidly so in 2011 alone
what we saw was that prices came down by
about 40 percent
most observers attribute this in large
part to massive entry
from new manufacturers into the industry
primarily from china at this point
if you look at commercial scale
installations and by that we're
referring to businesses that are
installing solar panels on their
rooftops and warehouses
we find that at least in select
locations with high retail prices solar
pv has already achieved cost
competitiveness
so that applies primarily
to regions like southern california or
the southwestern united states
two important qualifiers on this
location is like in real estate location
is everything
so if you move this to other parts of
the country the equation changes quickly
and the second thing that i mentioned
before
federal subsidies play an important role
in that calculation if you took those
away at the moment
the cost of solar pv would probably rise
by more than 50 percent okay
for another segment of this market is
utility scale installations and there we
find that basically they are not yet
competitive with fossil fuels
at least at this point
in fact there remains about a 30
gap the reason that is harder
to achieve cost competitiveness here is
that prices have to be compared to
wholesale electricity prices rather than
retail electricity prices
over the past 30 years the solar pv
industry has really shown a remarkable
confirmation of the so-called 80
learning curve and we've seen this
learning curve in other industries
like semiconductors and aircraft
manufacturing and roughly what this
means is that every time you double
the total cumulative amount of solar
panels produced
costs drop by another 20 percent
so if this pattern were to hold up in
the future and the world continues to
install solar pv at the same rate over
the next couple of years we think and
you will forgive the pun the future of
solar looks pretty bright
so in particular we think that utility
scale installations are on track to
become competitive by the end of this
decade
and at the same time
for commercial scale installations which
as i mentioned before are already cost
competitive in the current environment
they could even achieve the next level
of great parity which would mean that
they would become cost competitive even
without the current subsidies
so bottom line on this is
contrary to what some people have argued
solar pv probably does not need a major
technological breakthrough if we just
stay on the current path
the chances are very good that within 10
years
great parity is achievable but this will
require that for the time being public
subsidies remain in place for sustained
volume and sustained cost reductions
you